we've spent several videos already
talking about graphs like you see here
this is the graph for a particular firm
maybe it's making donuts so it's in the
donut industry and we can see how the
marginal cost relates to the average
variable cost and average total cost we
go into some depth several videos ago
but we see that trend that marginal cost
can trend down initially because as
quantity increases each incremental unit
could benefit from things like
specialization and then the marginal
cost the cost of each incremental unit
as a function of quantity could go up
because of things like coordination
costs and then we've also seen how that
relates to average variable costs that
while marginal cost is below average
variable cost every incremental unit is
going to bring down the average variable
cost but then when marginal cost crosses
average variable cost well now every
incremental unit is going to bring up
the average variable cost and the same
thing happens once it crosses the
average total cost and of course the
difference between for any given
quantity between the average total cost
and the average variable cost that is
the average fixed cost now that out of
the way we're going to think about how
this firm would react under different
market conditions we're going to assume
that it's in a very competitive or we
could say a perfectly competitive market
and so it is a price taker and so let's
first imagine what would be a positive
scenario for this firm let's imagine the
price up here so let's call this
p
sub 1
and in a previous video we already said
it would be rational for profit
maximizing firm to produce at a quantity
where the marginal cost and the marginal
revenue is meat
and if we're talking about a competitive
market then the this price right over
here is not going to be a function of
the firm's quantity so that's why it's
horizontal and it would be
a the same thing as the marginal revenue
so in this situation at p sub 1 the firm
would produce
q sub 1.
and this is a good situation for the
firm because the price that it's getting
is higher than its average total cost
and so there is going to be a nice
amount of profit for this farm the
profit is going to be the price
minus the average total cost at that
quantity times the actual quantity so
because p1 is greater than the average
total cost
we have a situation where the firm is
profitable
firm
is profitable
it would want to stay in the market but
because you have a profitable firm in
this market and you're likely to have
many profitable firms in that market it
will probably attract entrants
attract
attract entrants other people might say
hey i want to
make just as much money as this donut
company right over here than this firm
and so you'll probably have more and
more entrance into the market which will
probably reduce the prices
now they could reduce the prices until
you get to a price that looks something
like this so i will call that p sub 2.
now a profit maximizing firm in this
world would keep producing until the
marginal cost is equal to the marginal
revenue which in this case is the price
and so this would be
my lines aren't completely straight
there but you get the idea so that's q
sub 2.
now in this situation p sub 2 is equal
to the average total cost so the firm is
break even
it's not running at a loss or a profit
so it is break even and so here the firm
is neutral about whether in the long run
it stays in the market or it exits the
market but you're no longer likely a
tracking entrance so no
longer
attracting
attracting
entrants
but it does make sense for the firm to
keep operating at this situation even in
the long run because it is at least
break even
now let's imagine another scenario let's
imagine
this price level
so for whatever reason the market price
gets to that as we've talked about a
rational firm would be producing at q
sub 3
and at p sub 3 right over here there's
some interesting things because p sub 3
is less than your average total cost
your firm is running at a loss
it's running at a loss here so running
so firm
firm
not profitable
not profitable now you might say well
what is this firm likely to do would it
would it just shut down well in the
short run it would not make sense for
this firm to shut down because the price
that it's getting is still higher than
its average variable cost in the short
run the fixed costs they've already been
spent so you might as well get as much
incremental profit on the margin as you
can and so as long as the price is
higher than the average variable cost
well outside of their fixed cost they're
still making some money to make up those
fixed costs
so you have two things going on so they
would stay operating in the short run
stay
operating
operating
in the short run
short run
but what would this firm do in the long
run well in the long run it makes no
sense to have a
to be in a market where you can't make a
profit so in the long run it will exit
so it will exit in
the
long
run and in general the terminology when
people are talking about well do you
start or stop in the short run they
usually talk about do you either shut
down or operate in the short run and
then in the long run where it's like hey
do are you going to sell your factories
or or or somehow dismantle them or are
you going to build new factories that's
all about exiting or entering the
industry
and of course you have another even
worse scenario for this firm which might
be down here
where you have price sub 4.
here in theory this is where we
intersect the marginal cost curve q sub
4.
now here it makes no sense for the
company to operate at all so because p
sub 4 is less than the average total
cost
you would want to exit
in the long run exit in long run exit
the market
but you wouldn't even wait for that long
wait to sell your factories because c p
sub 4 is less than your average variable
cost you would also just shut down
shut down
in
the
short
run
so big picture from a firm's point of
view you obviously want to be at p1
where you make a profit but you might
attract entrance
at p sub 2 you as a firm in the long run
are neutral versus exiting the market or
entering the market or other people
entering the market you're at break even
at p sub 3
in
the long run you'd want to exit because
you're not profitable if the prices stay
at p sub 3 your price is below your
average total cost at the rational
quantity to produce so in the long run
you would exit
but because p sub 3
is greater than your average variable
cost at the rational quantity you would
stay operating in the short run and then
the last scenario of course is p sub 4
where the price gets so low that just
doesn't make sense to even operate
another moment